are you ready to unlock the power of
HubSpot as a leading CRM platform Hudson
has revolutionized how businesses
connect with customers so brace yourself
for some incredible impact picture this
businesses using HubSpot witnessed a
significant increase in the lead to
customer conversion rate National
inbound marketing generate three times
as many as leads as outbound marketing
and costs around 62 percent less but
wait there's more companies that access
at lead nurturing generate 50 more sales
ready leads at 33 lower cost with
hubspot's free CRM you will have all
your custom data at your fingertips
boosting efficiency and personalization
so say hello to data treatment decision
making and bid farewell to guesswork
plus half sort grows with you supporting
your businesses at every step so get
ready to attract engage and Delight
customers like never before because in
this video we will talk about HubSpot
your secret weapon to success but before
we begin make sure you have liked this
video And subscribe to our channel for
more such videos and hit the Bell icon
for all notifications now before we get
into the nitty-gritty of things let me
ask you something are you aspiring to
become a digital marketing Powerhouse
because simply learn Sports graduate
program in digital marketing is your
gateway to success this comprehensive
program offers a deep dive into the
world of digital marketing equipping you
with the skills and knowledge needed to
excel in this rapidly evolving industry
gain expertise in SEO social media
marketing content marketing analytics
and more and guess what you will get to
master the renowned CRM platform HubSpot
we will provide you with hands-on
experience in leveraging this
cutting-edge marketing tool imagine
harnessing the power of hubspot's
marketing Hub to drive targeted
campaigns and convert leads into loyal
customers which simply runs
post-graduate program in digital
marketing you will be armed with
industry relevant skills and
certifications so are you ready to take
on any marketing challenge don't miss
out on this opportunity to transform
your career enroll now and Unleash Your
digital marketing potential the course
link is in the description and if you
are still not con then listen to what
one of our Learners has to say about our
course change is inevitable but growth
is optional
for me both came hand in hand
I successfully changed my career from
software development to digital
marketing and simply learned present at
the perfect route hi I'm rimajraf from
Dubai and I have completed the pgp in
digital marketing from Simply learn with
Purdue University when I shifted to
Dubai from Sri Lanka in 2015 I joined a
group of company as a software engineer
but my interest in content creation
attracted me towards the marketing
industry intrigued by the marketing
functions I decided to take up a
challenge that would change my life
forever I aim for a career change as
risky as it was the rewards were truly
overwhelming even though the journey
wasn't easy the pgp in digital marketing
with Purdue University acted as not only
a catalyst but a game changer for my
career change with no profiling
certification in marketing domain it was
difficult for me to transition and
change my career towards completely
so I decided to upskill with the
professional certification program
I just simply learn because of its
tremendously High waiting to be rated as
one of the best Education portal online
worldwide is surely promising not only
were the ratings I but also the courses
were economically charged the modules
were very informative and amazing I
still refer to those while in the final
stage of my course I told my Superior
about the certification program I was
doing and they offered me a digital
marketing role in the marketing
department as a digital marketing
executive is that's how smooth it was
after working for a few years in the
same company as a digital marketing
executive I switched to a new role as a
digital marketing manager with this my
skill upgraded my salary increase and my
self-confident Boost alongside numerous
other positive outcomes I had a chance
to take a challenge and change my career
domain all together
and I took it So currently I am pursuing
masters of Masters program from Simply
learn where I would complete eight
Masters program including artificial
intelligent cloud computing and devops
and many more growing requires moving
out of our comfort zones
keep learning keep growing now without
any further Ado let's talk about CRM
CRM a customer relationship management
is a strategy and set of tools that
businesses use to manage and analyze
customer interactions it involves
capturing and organizing customer data
in a centralized database enabling
businesses to understand and meet
customer needs CRM system tracks
customer interactions across various
channels and provides a holistic view of
each customer now let's talk about the
protagonist of this video HubSpot
HubSpot is a game-changing all-in-one
CRM platform that revolutionizes how
businesses attract engage and Delight
customers with HubSpot businesses can
streamline processes automate tasks and
gain valuable insights to drive growth
and enhance customer relationships its
marketing Hub optimizes content and
analyze marketing performance
the sales Hub empowers sales teams with
pipeline management and automation the
service Hub ensures exceptional customer
service through support ticket system
and feedback collection plus HubSpot
offers a free CRM centralizing customer
data with interactions businesses
benefit from improved efficiency
personalized experiences data driven
decision making and scalability HubSpot
is the ultimate solution for businesses
seeking success in this digital era and
it's time to Leverage The Power of
HubSpot and unlock your full potential
now let's go over to the HubSpot website
and learn how to do work with HubSpot
now here we are at the hubspot.com now
we can go ahead and choose either one of
the options get a demo or get started
for free you will start for free then I
will continue as Google to make account
now let's type in what kind of industry
are you in or marketing
then we will go next then as an lob role
it's already selected CEO
then as a company name let's give it a
demo account
next
let's say 200 2000
then www dot demo
account.com
something like this then next
then it is we are based on us
then it will get our account ready let's
answer some of some more questions like
I have never used this what would you
like to do with HubSpot first so
we want to create a high performance
sales tools or something like that so we
can choose whatever you want let's skip
without picking a goal then what kind of
services we need and all that
now as you can see we have different and
kinds of hubs here like marketing Hub
sales Hub service Hub operation shop and
CMS Hub now what we want to start first
we want to create our context first so
we will go here contacts
these are some demo contacts
now let's create a email so let's say
dummy account
at the rate
Gmail
.com
first name
dummy last name account
contact on a web
job role
let's say marketing
manager
let's give it the demo number
life cycle stage you can choose anything
subscriber leads marketing qualified
leads sales qualified leads
opportunities customer
evangelist or even others if you have
something else so let's take marketing
qualifiedly
then you can also choose what is the
lead status like it's new open in
progress open Deal unqualified attempt
to contract connected so let's give it
open
and create and as you can see it has
created a complete profile here
with everything what we have just
selected
then here we will it will show us our
activities and overview activities what
happen and all that then we can we also
have an inbox you can go to inbox
here it will show everything from emails
to chats to forms to uh you can also
connect your Facebook messenger and all
that you can also use to create ads
emails landing page and all let's go
over to ads as you can see you can
connect your accounts and all that for
your ads account Google ads account and
all that to uh manage all your Facebook
Instagram LinkedIn and Google ads
campaign and all that and then we also
have emails
let's try and create an email so let's
get started
this letter then we'll create an email
and a regular email
we will select a template and what we
have here is that what company logos and
all that so you can change it here you
can also edit text
like enroll
in our
course
what are the benefits
what are the USPS
you can say best course
available
and something like this
then thanks your company name and all
that
then you can also select this
unsubscribe manage my friends and these
buttons
you can add some kind of pictures here
you can also design it like in template
if you want to change the background
color or set a background pattern body
color
text to it at the border and all that
textiles what kind of style you want to
use
if you want to use a button what color
should that be you know and dividers
then you will go to settings settings
you will add subject line what you want
to so
enroll now
if you text anything because
description
then you can choose subscription type
it's one on one right now or you can add
subscription
you can select a subscription type any
kind of language so let's use English
subscription name ABC
description ABC
ABV
and create
like that we can create any kind of
subscription
now let's get back to the emails the one
we were working on after all this you
can select subscription type like ABC we
just created you can also set a foot
footer module
so basically you can write up the
details about your company its office
locations and all that
then we have plant tags
repeat
then we have plain text
then you can also send or schedule it so
select recipient so we have our dummy
account we can select that so sending
limit we have we had already selected
two thousand you can now send now or
schedule for later
like schedule here
we also have something called automation
so I will explore on my own
as you can see it has a lock here so
basically it means is
you will need to upgrade to a CRM suits
starter
so let's review and send
View
so in the mobile it will looks like this
in the PC it will look like this
select a contact tummy account
it's for the client
we have to first clear all all our
errors
now let's say company name so ABC
address
ABC and City terminal state
now that save changes
now let's review and send and now we can
send let's send it
as you can see send email now
and it's
it said now let's Explore More you can
also create landing pages here you can
build your lead caption campaigns with
the landing pages so you can create a
website page or landing page
let's explore both of them so for
website this is the website which it
will give you can give a page name like
demo form
and create a page
and what you will do is you will choose
themes you have to install a theme with
theme forest but I don't feel like going
into it so you can explore that on your
own we also have landing pages it will
be the similarly
same you will need to create a template
so let's select template or something
here if you can here's the select
template then it it's showing us
then what we can do is we can choose how
we want to show this so for a mobile it
will look like this
as for the PC it will look a lot like
this you can change what you want to
change here
you can change the image
whatever you like
so this will be an easier work if you
want to do and for the content like
optimize how you want to optimize like
these should be unique so that as for
SEO purposes and all that then you can
when you are good with that you can just
publish it here you have to collect the
like page title what you want to do like
like I just showed you you need to name
everything and all that for SEO purposes
and for this
we also it also has a run ENB test to
and run adapt to test these are locked
you have to upgrade it
then we also have site Navigator you can
go to site here like ending page and all
that let's exit it for now
then we also you can also visit website
like this
then social SEO campaign these are all
the tools that you can use
account for this then in the sales we
have deals you can create a deal here
let's create one
test
so pipeline will be scene swipe line
for these days let's say qualified to
buy let's give it a thousand dollars
let's select today's date then deal type
existing business priority
medium high what you want to give
for contact Let's uh let's use our dummy
account again then add a line item right
now we don't have any item set up so we
can just delete this part as well then
create
then you can see here's the product
amount thousand
when it is which should be close then
stage qualified to buy you can change it
here as well
then dloner about this deal deal type
existing business and all that you can
select check activities what activities
it will be happening with that let's say
it's close in one we cannot change it
like here the contact details are given
here for the person so you can show
actions here like you want to unfollow
this or view all property and all that
now let's see we have forecast here
again you need to upgrade to sales are
professional to access these things
and task
what kind of task you want to do you can
create tasks as well as a
let's task test
type to do you want to kick all email
anything what's the priority here let's
say hi then you can
associate it with Records who want to
assign it you in how many days it has to
be done like in a two days three days in
a week as well time
then you can also set it to repeat as
well
you can select a reminder like
at the time of that 30 minutes before
one hour before one day before and all
that you can also select custom video
then some kind of note you want to give
it and create then next we have
something called tickets now we have
already talked about one of its features
called tickets it you can generate
tickets here create tickets the that
will help you track issues with your
customers have so it's a hub customers
will create tickets
now so let's say
test tickets then pipeline
whatever the issue would be take a
description what is the description
source
so take it on its me and all that you
can also set priority here this is also
that we can seamlessly uh respond to our
customers complaints and requests then
rest of the features like automation
sequencer workflows are all available
with the pro account
then for reports we have analytics tools
these are also locked with professional
account then dashboard
you can create any kind of dashboard
let's say new dashboard dashboard name
test
who can see if you can put it to private
for yourself only or everyone to view
and edit or view only let's set view
only create dashboard so we can go to
our dashboard now as for dashboard you
can add reports through this dashboard
from Saved reports
their notable reports as right now so we
can create report as well
these are logged but you understand what
I'm saying right
so let's let's exit it from here
so I've already told you about reports
then data management we have data module
data quantity and data sets as well as
integration I will explore on my own you
can connect your apps your social media
and all that you can integrate
everything here so it's uh everything is
on one place for you to manage
and
Tata model
you can create you can choose your own
data model for your company and all that
like what kind of activities you want to
do what are CRM objects what are the
activities you can choose who will do
what now let me show you the
what are the trials and all that
let's see pricing
so for a starter you can either pay
upfront commit annually so annually it
will be around to 16 years as a starter
for a professional it will be 800 per
month or 900 9600
uh per year you can also set up set a
deal with the company and choose
according to your benefit your use and
there you have it a brief tutorial on
HubSpot we have only scratched the
surface of what this powerful marketing
tool can do but I hope it has given you
a good overview and sparked your
interest remember HubSpot offers
extensive documentation training
resources and a supportive Community to
help you along the way and with that
thanks for watching and if you found
this video helpful and informational
then up for this video And subscribe to
our Channel and if you have any
suggestions or questions then feel free
to drop them in the comment section
below until next time stay safe and keep
learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here